Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂产业产生了显著的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在迈向净零排放的道路上取得进展。投资于技术和创新。平均每桶排放量已减少22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位。开发世界上最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
The crime scene was described as looking more like the set of a horror movie than real life. It was one of the most horrific crimes ever committed. Not only did it shock the small town of Aberdeen in country New South Wales, it shocked the entire nation, even parts of the world. What could possibly drive somebody to do this? A psychiatric illness? Or premeditated, preplanned, pure evil? Catherine Knight was born on the 24th of October 1955.
这个犯罪现场被形容为更像是一部恐怖电影的片场，而不是现实生活。这是有史以来最可怕的罪行之一。它不仅震惊了新南威尔士州乡村小镇阿伯丁，还震惊了整个国家，甚至世界某些地方。究竟是什么驱使一个人做出这种事？精神疾病？还是预谋的、处心积虑的纯粹恶魔行径？凯瑟琳·奈特于1955年10月24日出生。
She is a non-identical twin. Catherine was the more feminine of the twins. She liked to help her mum around the house, assist with the cooking and cleaning, and liked playing with the dolls. Cathy Knight's parents were Ken Knight and Barbara Knight, who married each other in 1952. Cathy's father left school at the age of 14 to work at the Abattoir in Aberdeen, country New South Wales, where he lived at the time. He later met Barbara and married her.
她是一个异卵双胞胎。凯瑟琳是双胞胎中更具女性化的一员。她喜欢帮妈妈做家务，协助烹饪和打扫卫生，还喜欢玩洋娃娃。凯茜·奈特的父母是肯·奈特和芭芭拉·奈特，他们于1952年结婚。凯茜的父亲在14岁时辍学，前往他当时居住的新南威尔士州乡村阿伯丁的屠宰场工作。他后来遇到了芭芭拉并与她结婚。
They moved to Queensland and to various parts of New South Wales, where Ken continued to work as a slaughterman at the Abattoirs. He was considered excellent at his job and a very hard worker. Barbara had a short fuse temper. She was hot-headed and loved using excessive foul language. Barbara and Ken were in a strict household. The kids did as I was told, there was no mucking about. There were six kids in the house altogether, including Cathy.
他们搬到了昆士兰州和新南威尔士州的各个地方，肯继续在屠宰场担任屠宰工。他被认为工作非常出色，是个极其勤奋的人。芭芭拉的脾气很急躁。她性情火爆，极其喜欢说粗话。芭芭拉和肯的家庭管理很严格。孩子们必须听从吩咐，不准胡闹。家里总共有六个孩子，包括凯茜。
After moving around to various parts of the state and in estate, they finally settled back in Aberdeen in 1969. Aberdeen is a small country town located in the Upper Hunter region of New South Wales, about 240 kilometres, which is about 150 miles north of Sydney. The main source of employment for the people of Aberdeen at the time was the local Abattoir. There wasn't much else going on in the small country town that had a population of about 1,500 people. As a kid, Cathy wasn't allowed to have pets, but she loved animals. If she came across an injured animal like a bird with an injured wing,
在搬迁到该州和各地的不同地方后，他们终于在1969年重新定居在阿伯丁。阿伯丁是位于新南威尔士州上亨特地区的一个小型乡村小镇，距离悉尼向北约240公里（约合150英里）。当时阿伯丁人民的主要就业来源是当地的屠宰场。这个人口约1,500人的小乡村镇并没有太多其他活动。小时候，凯茜不被允许养宠物，但她很喜欢动物。如果她遇到受伤的动物，比如翅膀受伤的鸟，
she would bring it home and look after it until it was better. From a young age, she showed that she had a fiery temper. On bus rides to and from school, some of the boys used to torment her and give her a hard time. But Cathy Knight could look after herself. She was involved in more than one fistfight with the boys at school, and she could more than hold her own. It's likely Cathy inherited her fiery temper and love of fair language from her mother Barbara. Cathy left school at the age of 15.
她会把它带回家照顾，直到它痊愈。从小时候起，她就表现出火爆的脾气。在上下学的公交车上，一些男孩经常捉弄她，给她制造麻烦。但凯茜·奈特能照顾好自己。她与学校的男孩打过不止一次群架，而且完全能够应付自如。凯茜火爆的脾气和对粗话的喜爱很可能是遗传自她的母亲芭芭拉。凯茜在15岁时辍学。
She had achieved only a bare minimum level of reading and writing skills. There was only one thing she wanted to do when she left school, following her father's footsteps and work at the Aberdeen Abattoir. Her first application was rejected, but she applied again in 1971, and she was successful the second time. She was 16 years old when she started work. Cathy started as a general labourer, mopping up the blood and cleaning up the animal flesh and carcasses.
她的读写能力仅达到了最低标准。她离开学校后只想做一件事，那就是追随父亲的脚步，在阿伯丁屠宰场工作。她的第一次申请被拒绝了，但她在1971年再次申请，第二次成功了。她开始工作时只有16岁。凯茜从普通零工做起，擦拭血迹，清理动物肉块和胴体。
She then moved her way up to become a slicer, which she enjoyed immensely. She loved her job and she was very good at it. She was very efficient and precise with a knife. Cathy took pride in her knives. She always kept them in top condition. As she grew older, Cathy was described as generally kind-natured and helpful, with a heart of gold. She was average-looking, tall, slim, with red hair, and she wore glasses. She liked to make her own clothes. She was good at knitting. She played bingo.
然后她晋升为切肉工，她对此非常享受。她热爱自己的工作，并且干得非常出色。她做事高效，用刀精准。凯茜为自己的刀具感到自豪。她总是把它们保持在最佳状态。随着年龄的增长，凯茜被描述为总体上心地善良、乐于助人、有一颗金子般的心。她长相平平，身材高大修长，有一头红发，戴着眼镜。她喜欢自己做衣服。她擅长织毛衣。她打宾果游戏。
There was nothing spectacular about her at all. But there was a dark side to Cathy. A very dark side. There was her fiery temper, constant use of foul language, and dark, violent behaviour. Cathy was somebody you didn't want to get on the wrong side of. She was as vindictive as anyone could be. If you did the wrong thing by Cathy,
她身上一点也没有什么特别耀眼的地方。但凯茜有着黑暗的一面。非常黑暗的一面。她有着火爆的脾气、满嘴的粗话以及黑暗暴力的行为。凯茜是那种你绝对不想惹毛的人。她有着极强的报复心。如果你对凯茜做了错事，
she would do everything in her power to get you back ten times worse. It was whilst working at the Aberdeen Abattoir in 1973 that Cathy met her first husband, David Kelly. It was a quick romance and they quickly got married. It wasn't much of a wedding. They hopped on a motorbike together, rode to the local registry office, which was in a nearby town called Musselbrook, and then they celebrated the wedding with friends at a local pub.
她会竭尽所能十倍奉还。正是在1973年于阿伯丁屠宰场工作期间，凯茜遇到了她的第一任丈夫大卫·凯利。这是一场迅速的恋情，他们很快就结婚了。这算不上什么盛大的婚礼。他们一起骑着摩托车，前往附近一个叫马塞尔布鲁克的镇上的当地登记处，然后在当地的一家酒吧里和朋友们一起庆祝婚礼。
Cathy was 18 at the time. It didn't take long for David to get his first taste of the dark side of Cathy. It was that night, actually. David had drunk excessively all day and he was struggling to perform to Cathy's liking in the bedroom. When he fell asleep, she woke him up by putting her hands around his neck and strangling him. Cathy let David know she wasn't happy.
凯茜当时18岁。大卫没过多久就首次领略到了凯茜黑暗的一面。其实，就是在那天晚上。大卫整天酗酒，在卧室里表现得无法让凯茜满意。当他睡着时，她把手放在他的脖子上掐住了他，以此把他弄醒。凯茜让大卫知道她很不高兴。
Despite this incident, the marriage actually started out quite well. That kind natured, helpful, hard of gold version of Cathy couldn't have been happier. But after about a year, things started to turn sour. Cathy's temper and mood swings started to take off and things got worse and worse and gradually turned very violent. By the time Cathy had given birth to their first daughter, Melissa, David had had enough and he took off to Queensland with another woman,
尽管发生了这起事件，这段婚姻实际上还是开局不错。那个善良、乐于助人、拥有一颗金子般的心版本的凯茜当时感到无比幸福。但大约一年后，事情开始变味了。凯茜的脾气和情绪波动开始爆发，情况变得越来越糟，并逐渐演变成极其暴力的行径。到了凯茜生下他们的第一个女儿梅丽莎时，大卫已经忍无可忍，他带着另一个女人逃到了昆士兰，
who also happened to be pregnant to him. It was 1976. This left Cathy feeling crushed and heartbroken. But also furious. She decided to take her anger out on their daughter, Melissa. She walked down to the local railway tracks and left Melissa right in the middle of them. A local man happened to walk past at the right time
那个女人当时也怀上了他的孩子。那是1976年。这让凯茜感到崩溃和心碎。但也极其愤怒。她决定将怒火发泄在他们的女儿梅丽莎身上。她走到当地的铁轨旁，把梅丽莎直接留在了铁轨正中间。正好有一个当地人路过，
and saw Melissa on the tracks. He quickly ran down and saved her. A train came through not long after that. Later that day, Cathy picked up an axe and started swinging it around, threatening numerous people. Police were called and they took her to a local hospital for a mental health assessment. But she was released soon after.
看到了铁轨上的梅丽莎。他赶忙跑过去救了她。没过多久，一辆火车驶过。那天晚些时候，凯茜拿起一把斧头四处挥舞，威胁了许多人。警察被叫来，并将她带到当地医院进行心理健康评估。但她不久后就被释放了。
Only a few days later, on the 3rd of August, 1976, Cathy went to the house of one of her co-workers, Molly Perry. She asked Molly for help, telling her that Melissa was sick and she needed a lift to the doctors. Molly was only too happy to help her out and together with her mother and younger brother, she put Cathy in the car to drive her to the doctors. But Melissa wasn't sick at all.
仅仅几天后的1976年8月3日，凯茜来到了她的同事莫莉·佩里家。她向莫莉寻求帮助，说梅丽莎生病了，她需要搭车去看医生。莫莉非常乐意帮忙，并在她母亲和弟弟的协助下，让凯茜上了车，开车送她去看医生。但梅丽莎根本没生病。
Soon after getting in Molly's car, Cathy pulled out a butcher's knife and held it up to Molly, slashing her on the cheek. She demanded that Molly drive her to Coffs Harbour, which is about a six-hour drive away. Coffs Harbour is where David Kellett's mother, Jean, lived. Cathy later admitted her plan was to ask Jean why David left her, then kill her,
上了莫莉的车后不久，凯茜掏出一把屠刀指向莫莉，并在她的脸颊上划了一刀。她要求莫莉开车送她去科夫斯港，那里开车大约需要六个小时。科夫斯港是大卫·凯莱特的母亲让娜居住的地方。凯茜后来承认，她的计划是先问让娜大卫为什么离开她，然后杀了她，
and then commit suicide. Instead, though, Molly drove to a nearby service station to try and get help. Cathy got out of the car, dragging Molly's younger brother out with her, holding the knife up to him. The police were called and quickly arrived. They were able to disarm Cathy using broomsticks.
最后自杀。然而，莫莉却把车开到了附近的一个加油站试图寻求帮助。凯茜下了车，把莫莉的弟弟也拖下车，并将刀架在他脖子上。警察被叫来并迅速赶到。他们用扫帚柄成功解除了凯茜的武装。
One of the officers received a small cut in the struggle. Again, Cathy was taken to hospital for a psychiatric assessment. While Cathy was being treated in hospital, Melissa was looked after by Cathy's parents, Barbara and Ken. Cathy was diagnosed with a personality disorder. When suffering from personality disorder, a person can be loving and caring one minute before losing complete control
其中一名警官在搏斗中受了轻伤。凯茜再次被送往医院接受精神评估。在凯茜于医院接受治疗期间，梅丽莎由凯茜的父母芭芭拉和肯照顾。凯茜被诊断出患有人格障碍。当患有人格障碍时，一个人前一分钟可能还充满爱心和关怀，下一分钟就会完全失控，
and being capable of dangerous, violent behaviour the next minute. David Kellett was still up in Queensland at the time when he got a call from police about the incident. He returned home and visited Cathy in hospital with his mother, Jean. A hearing was held in hospital on the 9th of August, 1976, and it was decided Cathy could be released into the care of Jean and David. This was only six days after the incident. Jean and David were given strict instructions
并且随时可能做出危险、暴力的行为。当时大卫·凯莱特还在昆士兰，他接到了警察关于这起事件的电话。他返回家中，和母亲让娜一起在医院探望了凯茜。1976年8月9日，医院举行了一场听证会，决定将凯茜释放并交由让娜和大卫监护。这距离事件发生仅仅过去了六天。让娜和大卫得到了严格的指示，
to make sure Cathy took all of her medication. It didn't take long for another violent incident to happen. Actually, it happened pretty much straight away. As soon as they left the hospital, they drove to Cathy's parents' house to pick up Melissa. As soon as they got there, Barbara stormed out of the house and attacked David. She grabbed him around the throat and screamed at him, blaming him for Cathy's breakdown.
务必确保凯茜服用了所有的药物。暴力事件没过多久就再次上演了。事实上，几乎是立刻就发生了。他们一离开医院，就开车去凯茜父母家接梅丽莎。一到那里，芭芭拉就冲出屋子袭击了大卫。她抓住他的喉咙对他尖叫，将凯茜的崩溃归咎于他。
Cathy responded by getting out of the car, walking out to Barbara and punching her in the face, knocking her to the ground. Cathy then stood over Barbara and screamed, Don't ever touch David again. After this, David and Cathy got back together. They moved to Queensland together and Cathy got a job as a meat slicer in an abattoir up there.
凯茜的反应是下车走到芭芭拉面前，一拳打在她的脸上，将她击倒在地。随后，凯茜站在芭芭拉身旁尖叫道：“再也不准碰大卫。”在那之后，大卫和凯茜复合了。他们一起搬到了昆士兰，凯茜在那里的一家屠宰场找到了一份切肉工的工作。
Cathy was in love with her knives. So much so, she asked David to mount them for her so she could keep them in the bedroom, just in case she needed them. But it didn't take long for the relationship problems to strike again. Cathy's mood and temper was still there. She was controlling and demanding and couldn't let David's affair go.
凯茜深爱着她的刀具。以至于她要求大卫为她把刀具安装好，好让她能把它们放在卧室里，以防自己不时之需。但两人的关系没过多久就再次出现了问题。凯茜的脾气和情绪依然如故。她充满控制欲且要求严格，始终无法释怀大卫的出轨。
There were plenty of arguments between them and a lot of them were physical. Cathy was the reason they were physical. She attacked David with punches and kitchen pots and frying pans and anything else she could get her hands on. Cathy also had an affair with a co-worker from the abattoir where she worked. It was payback for David's affair. David actually walked in on them in bed together.
他们之间爆发了大量争吵，其中许多都是肢体冲突。凯茜是引发肢体冲突的罪魁祸首。她用拳头、厨房里的锅具、平底锅以及她能拿到的任何东西袭击大卫。凯茜还与她工作的屠宰场的一名同事发生了婚外情。这是对大卫出轨的报复。大卫实际上当场撞见了他们睡在同一张床上。
But regardless, he still wanted to try and make the marriage work and not long after, him and Cathy had another baby, their second daughter, Natasha. Cathy would do things like tell David to go to the pub, have a few beers, but then ring the pub and demand him to come home immediately. One night when he arrived home from the pub much later than she wanted, she whacked him over the head with a frying pan
但无论如何，他仍然想要试着维持这段婚姻。不久之后，他和凯茜又生了一个孩子，即他们的第二个女儿娜塔莎。凯茜经常会做出这样的举动：让大卫去酒吧喝几杯啤酒，然后又打电话给酒吧，要求他立刻回家。有一天晚上，他从酒吧回家的时间比她希望的要晚得多，他刚一进门，
as soon as he walked through the door. It put David in hospital, but he didn't press charges. Not long after that, during another argument, Cathy held a knife up to David's throat. And another night when Cathy wasn't happy with David, she poured petrol all over his clothes and set them on fire. Cathy's behaviour was troubling and becoming increasingly more violent. Barbara Knight actually warned David at one time,
她就用平底锅猛砸他的头部。这导致大卫住进了医院，但他没有起诉。没过多久，在另一场争吵中，凯茜用刀架在大卫的脖子上。还有一次晚上，当凯茜对大卫不满时，她把汽油全倒在他的衣服上并点燃了它们。凯茜的行为令人担忧，并且变得越来越暴力。芭芭拉·奈特实际上曾警告过大卫：
don't play up on her, she'll kill you. Finally, in 1983, Cathy again whacked David over the head, splitting him open, put him in hospital yet again. But that was finally the end. David again didn't press charges, but he called the marriage off once and for all.
“别去招惹她，她会杀了你的。”最终，在1983年，凯茜再次用平底锅猛砸大卫的头部，把他的头打破了，再次把他送进了医院。但这终究是画上了句号。大卫再次没有提起诉讼，但他一劳永逸地结束了这段婚姻。
Cathy responded by cleaning the house out. She took everything, including the curtains and the light bulbs. But David couldn't have cared less. He was happy and grateful it was finally over, thinking there must be a God looking out for him somewhere. Cathy moved back to her parents' farm in Aberdeen with their two daughters, Melissa and Natasha. Cathy returned to work at the Aberdeen Abattoir
凯茜的反应是将房子洗劫一空。她拿走了所有东西，包括窗帘和灯泡。但大卫才不在乎呢。他感到高兴和感激，这一切终于结束了，他心想一定有神灵在某处保佑着他。凯茜带着他们两个女儿梅丽莎和娜塔莎搬回了父母位于阿伯丁的农场。凯茜重返阿伯丁屠宰场工作，
back to her role as a meat slicer. But in 1984, she heard it back. She never fully recovered and her employment at the Abattoir was terminated. It wasn't long before Cathy was in another relationship, this time with David Saunders, who she met at the Aberdeen Bowling Club. Just like her relationship with David Kellett,
回到了她切肉工的角色。但在1984年，她背部受伤了。她从未完全康复，她在屠宰场的雇佣关系也就此终止。没过多久，凯茜又开始了另一段恋情，这一次是与大卫·桑德斯在一起，两人是在阿伯丁保龄球俱乐部认识的。就像她和大卫·凯莱特的关系一样，
her relationship with Saunders started off great. Both couldn't have been happier. But that dark side that lurked in Cathy was ever present, just waiting to come to the surface. One day, out of nowhere, Cathy snapped and started accusing Saunders of cheating on her. Her unpredictable violent behaviour made its first appearance. And it would go on like that for the next three years, on and off.
她与桑德斯的感情也是从美好开始的。两人都感到无比幸福。但潜伏在凯茜体内的那个黑暗面一直存在，正等待着浮出水面。有一天，毫无征兆地，凯茜突然情绪崩溃，开始指责桑德斯对她不忠。她那不可预测的暴力行为首次显现。在接下来的三年里，这种情况时断时续地继续着。
Cathy would be lovely and calm one day, unpredictable and violent the next. During one of their arguments, Cathy grabbed a knife and went out into the backyard and killed Saunders' dog. She slit its throat. She says she did this in retaliation for Saunders kicking her in the stomach when she told him she was pregnant.
凯茜有时可爱而平静，有时又捉摸不定且充满暴力。在一次争吵中，凯茜抓起一把刀走到后院，杀死了桑德斯的狗。她割断了它的喉咙。她说她这样做是为了报复桑德斯，因为当她告诉他自己怀孕时，他踢了她的肚子。
Saunders strongly denies this, and he says he never touched her. He says she just went out in the backyard for no reason, started going off on one of her violent tangents, started making accusations about him, and then slipped his dog's throat. Soon after that, Cathy took an overdose of pills and had to be rushed to the hospital.
桑德斯强烈否认这一点，并表示他从未碰过她。他说她只是无缘无故地走到后院，开始陷入某种暴力倾向，开始对他进行指责，然后就割断了他狗的喉咙。不久之后，凯茜过量服用药丸，不得不被紧急送往医院。
Cathy always maintained it was Saunders who was the violent one towards her, and she would only act out in self-defense and at times revenge, but Saunders always denied this. Despite the extreme ups and downs of the relationship, they ended up having a daughter together in 1988. In 1989, Cathy received a compensation payout
凯茜一直坚称是桑德斯对她实施了暴力，而她只是进行正当防卫有时甚至是报复，但桑德斯对此一直予以否认。尽管这段感情经历了极端的起起落落，但他们在1988年最终还是生下了一个女儿。1989年，凯茜因背部受伤获得了赔偿金，
for her back injury, $15,000 in total. She used the money to pay off the house that her and Saunders were living in, effectively making it her house. Not long after that, the relationship hit rock bottom. Several more serious arguments occurred, and Cathy was even issued a restraining order against Saunders,
总计15,000美元。她用这笔钱还清了她和桑德斯居住的房子的贷款，实际上这栋房子变成了她自己的。不久之后，两人的关系跌入谷底。更多严重的争吵相继发生，凯茜甚至对桑德斯申请了禁止令，
although Saunders maintained it was he who should have had the order against her. And it was proven right when Cathy stabbed him in the stomach with a pair of scissors during yet another violent argument. It wasn't a serious injury, it didn't even require medical attention, but it was enough to convince Saunders it was over. But it didn't remain over for long.
尽管桑德斯坚称应该对她申请禁止令的人是自己。事实证明他是对的，因为在又一次激烈的争吵中，凯茜用一把剪刀刺入了她的腹部。这不是重伤，甚至不需要医疗护理，但这足以让桑德斯确信一切都结束了。但这并没有持续太久。
They got back together soon after to give the relationship another go. But after several more violent arguments and Cathy cutting up and throwing out all of Saunders' clothes, the relationship finally ended for good. Meanwhile, anything David Kellett would send to his girls like Christmas presents, birthday cards, flowers, etc. Cathy wouldn't give to them. She would throw them out before the girls ever saw them.
他们很快又复合了，试图再给这段感情一次机会。但在经历了几次更激烈的争吵、凯茜剪碎并扔掉了桑德斯的所有衣服之后，这段关系最终彻底画上了句号。与此同时，大卫·凯莱特寄给女儿们的任何东西，比如圣诞礼物、生日贺卡、鲜花等，凯茜都不会给她们。在女儿们看到之前，她就会把它们扔掉。
She would then tell the girls their dad never sent them anything. After the relationship ended with Saunders, Cathy soon entered another relationship with John Chillingworth. Cathy didn't like to be alone. She always had to have someone and never took a long to find a new partner. Just like past relationships, the early days were brilliant. Chillingworth says Cathy was terrific to be with.
然后她会告诉女儿们，她们的爸爸从来没有给她们寄过任何东西。在与桑德斯的关系结束后，凯茜很快又开始了与约翰·奇林沃思的新恋情。凯茜不喜欢孤独。她总是需要身边有人，而且从不花很长时间就能找到新伴侣。就像过去的恋情一样，早期总是无比美好。奇林沃思说凯茜非常好相处。
He thought he had found the perfect soulmate. They met at the Aberdeen Abattoir 20 years earlier when Cathy had just started working there as a 16-year-old. But nothing happened between them then, and Chillingworth ended up moving away and got married. Chillingworth had only recently just returned to the area, and that's when he met Cathy again. As Chillingworth had been out of the area for a long time,
他以为自己找到了完美的灵魂伴侣。他们20年前在阿伯丁屠宰场相识，当时凯茜刚满16岁，刚开始在那里工作。但那时他们之间什么也没发生，奇林沃思最终搬走了并结了婚。奇林沃思最近才刚回到这个地区，正是在那时他再次遇到了凯茜。由于奇林沃思已经离开该地区很长时间，
he wasn't familiar with what were by now the legendary Cathy night stories. His mates quickly fuelled him in, but Chillingworth didn't care. He was convinced Cathy was the one for him. And not long into their relationship, Cathy felt pregnant with their first child, Cathy's fourth in all.
他对当时已经成为传说的“凯茜·奈特的故事”并不熟悉。他的朋友们很快为他补充了背景信息，但奇林沃思并不在乎。他坚信凯茜就是他命中注定的人。在他们关系开始不久后，凯茜就怀上了他们的第一个孩子，这也是凯茜的第四个孩子。
After this, Cathy's true colours started to shine, and the arguments and violent behaviour started. After one fight, she went and spent a night with her ex, David Saunders, and she couldn't wait to rub it in Chillingworth's face. There were also issues between Cathy's elder store to Melissa and Chillingworth. Melissa didn't think much of him, and the feeling was pretty much mutual. Chillingworth actually admitted that he hit Melissa on one occasion. He says he immediately regretted it.
在此之后，凯茜的本性开始显露，争吵和暴力行为也随之而来。在一次争吵后，她去和前男友大卫·桑德斯过夜，并且迫不及待地将此事在奇林沃思面前炫耀。凯茜的大女儿梅丽莎和奇林沃思之间也存在矛盾。梅丽莎看不起他，而这种感觉基本上是相互的。奇林沃思甚至承认他曾打过梅丽莎一次。他说他立刻就后悔了。
Cathy made sure to take revenge on Chillingworth for hitting Melissa. She smashed his false teeth. When he had a go at her over this, she responded by smashing his second pair of false teeth. Just like past relationships, one minute it was on and all was good, the next minute it was off and was filled with violence. Cathy gave birth to their son in 1991. Not long after their son's birth,
凯茜确保要为奇林沃思打了梅丽莎一事进行报复。她砸碎了他的假牙。当他因此对她发火时，她的回应是砸碎了他的第二副假牙。就像过去的恋情一样，前一分钟还风平浪静、一切安好，后一分钟就急转直下、充满暴力。凯茜于1991年生下了他们的儿子。在儿子出生后不久，
Cathy and Chillingworth got into a physical fight, and Chillingworth was charged with assault. Cathy also got a restraining order taken out against him. They separated, but it didn't last long. They soon got back together. But Cathy didn't withdraw the assault charge. They ended up going to court together that day. John was put on a good behaviour bond and given a fine.
凯茜和奇林沃思发生了肢体冲突，奇林沃思被指控袭击罪。凯茜还针对他申请了禁止令。他们分居了，但这并没有持续多久。他们很快又复合了。但凯茜并没有撤销袭击指控。他们最终在那天一起出庭了。约翰被判处行为良好保证金并处以罚款。
They then went home together. John was a heavy drinker which contributed to the relationship problems. But he actually did quit, and he went on to help with the Salvation Army and drug and alcohol counselling. It was through them in 1993 that he got a job opportunity in Queensland for two weeks. He took the job, but he liked Queensland so much that he ended up staying. His initial intention was to have Cathy and the kids move up there. But when Cathy went up to visit him,
随后他们一起回了家。约翰酗酒严重，这加剧了他们之间的感情问题。但他实际上确实戒酒了，并开始协助救世主军以及药物和酒精咨询工作。正是通过他们，他在1993年获得了在昆士兰工作两周的机会。他接受了这份工作，但他太喜欢昆士兰了，以至于最后留在了那里。他最初的打算让凯茜和孩子们搬过去。但当凯茜去那里探望他时，
another massive fight between them put an end to the relationship for good. Chillingworth didn't know it at the time, but Cathy had already started seeing a new man, John Price. By now, Cathy had been unemployed for eight years, getting by with her compensation payout and a fortnightly government pension. She had four kids to three fathers. The eldest was aged 17, the youngest was aged two. John Price was born on the 4th of April, 1955.
他们之间又一次爆发的大规模争吵彻底断送了这段感情。当时的奇林沃思并不知道，凯茜已经开始和一个新男人约会了，他就是约翰·普赖斯。到这个时候，凯茜已经失业八年了，靠着赔偿金和每两周一次的政府养老金度日。她与三个不同的男人生了四个孩子。最大的一岁17岁，最小的才两岁。约翰·普赖斯于1955年4月4日出生。
He was the eldest of six children. John Price had a limited education. When he left school at the age of 14, he could barely read and write. But he was a hard worker. He worked in heavy machinery, earth-moving equipment, trucking and mining. John married his wife Colleen and they had three children together, a son and two daughters. Tragedy struck John Price's family when his father and brother became involved
他是六个孩子中的老大。约翰·普赖斯的教育程度有限。他14岁辍学时，几乎不识字。但他是个刻苦耐劳的人。他从事重型机械、土方设备、卡车运输和采矿工作。约翰与妻子科琳结婚，两人育有三个孩子，一个儿子和两个女儿。当约翰·普赖斯的父亲和兄弟卷入一场激烈的家庭纠纷时，悲剧降临到了他的家族。
in a heated domestic dispute. His father picked up a gun and started to load it, so John's brother picked up a gun and tried to fire a warning shot at him. Unfortunately, he accidentally shot their mother. The death was ruled accidental and John's brother was charged with manslaughter. The loss of his mother devastated John. He looked for a job opportunity elsewhere so he could move away and he found one. Together with his wife Colleen and kids, they moved to Aberdeen in 1981.
他的父亲拿起枪并开始上膛，于是约翰的兄弟也拿起一把枪，试图向他开枪以示警告。不幸的是，他意外击中了他们的母亲。这起死亡被判定为意外，约翰的兄弟被控过失杀人罪。母亲的离世对约翰造成了沉重的打击。他寻找其他的工作机会以便搬走，并且成功找到了。他和妻子科琳及孩子们于1981年搬到了阿伯丁。
John was described as an easygoing, likeable character who got on with everybody he met. He had a laid back, carefree nature. He would do anything for anyone and never expect anything in return. He worked hard and loved to unwind with a beer with his mates at the end of a hard day. In 1988, he split up with his wife Colleen. They had been married for 15 years. It wasn't a bitter separation at all. To show what kind of person John was, after they had separated,
约翰被形容为一个性格随和、讨人喜欢、与遇到的人都能相处融洽的人。他有着随性、无忧无虑的性格。他愿意为任何人做任何事，从不指望得到回报。他工作努力，喜欢在辛苦工作一天后和死党们喝杯啤酒放松一下。1988年，他和妻子科琳分居了。他们已经结婚15年了。这并不是一次充满怨恨的分居。为了展现约翰是怎样的人，在他们分居后，
Colleen asked him to borrow money to fix a fridge. Instead, he bought her a brand new fridge. Another time when he found out Colleen was going on holidays, he slipped $500 into a bank account without her knowing. John was a regular at the Aberdeen Hotel, known to locals as the Toppub. It was one of two pubs in Aberdeen. It was known as the Toppub as it sat on the top of the hill.
科琳向他借钱修理冰箱。相反，他给她买了一台全新的冰箱。另一次，当他发现科琳要去度假时，他悄悄往她的银行账户里存入了500美元，而她毫不知情。约翰是阿伯丁酒店的常客，当地人称之为“顶楼酒吧”。它是阿伯丁仅有的两家酒吧之一。由于它坐落在山顶上，因此被称为顶楼酒吧。
The other pub in town was known as the Bottompub. I'm sure you can work that out. And it was at the Toppub where John Price met Cathy Knight. Cathy fell madly in love with John and she was determined to make the relationship last. She was sick of her failed relationships. She wanted this one to be forever. Cathy and John struck up a conversation and that was that. They became an item very quickly.
镇上的另一家酒吧被称为“底楼酒吧”。我相信你能明白其中的含义。正是在顶楼酒吧，约翰·普赖斯遇到了凯茜·奈特。凯茜疯狂地爱上了约翰，并决心让这段恋情持久。她已经厌倦了失败的感情。她希望这段能永远持续下去。凯茜和约翰搭上了话，事情就这样成了。他们很快确立了恋爱关系。
And the common theme throughout Cathy's relationships continued. The first few months were described as fantastic. Both of them were very happy together. It took about a year for the first major arguments to begin. And they went on and on from there. For no reason, Cathy became deeply paranoid that John was cheating on her. It seems that when David Kellett cheated on her back in her first marriage, it convinced Cathy that all her future partners were going to cheat on her.
凯茜各段恋情中贯穿的共同主题再次上演。头几个月被形容为美妙绝伦。两人在一起非常快乐。大约过了一年，第一次重大争吵开始了。并且从那以后便一发不可收拾。无缘无故地，凯茜开始深陷偏执，怀疑约翰对她不忠。似乎当大卫·凯莱特在她的第一段婚姻中出轨时，这让凯茜确信她未来所有的伴侣都会对她不忠。
Despite a few hiccups, Cathy eventually moved into John Price's house. But he wouldn't marry her. And this was a new sticking point in their relationship. John said he loved Cathy, but he wanted to make sure his children got his house. He didn't want Cathy to be entitled to any of it. That's the main reason he said that he wouldn't marry her. Slowly but surely the arguments escalated from verbal and turned physical. The relationship started to deteriorate.
尽管有一些波折，凯茜最终还是搬进了约翰·普赖斯的家。但他不愿意和她结婚。这是他们关系中的一个新的症结所在。约翰说他爱凯茜，但他想确保自己的孩子们能够继承他的房子。他不想让凯茜对这栋房子拥有任何权利。这就是他声称不愿与她结婚的主要原因。争吵慢慢但坚定地从口头升级为肢体冲突。两人的关系开始恶化。
It didn't help when John would occasionally slip up and call Cathy his ex-wife's name, Colleen. Worrying signs started to appear. Cathy mentioned several times that she would kill John. But everyone, including John, just shrugged it off as meaningless threats. During one argument she said to John, you'll never get me out of this house. I'll do you in first. But as time went on, Cathy could sense the relationship was starting to slip away.
当约翰偶尔不小心叫出凯茜前妻的名字“科琳”时，情况就更糟糕了。令人担忧的迹象开始出现。凯茜多次提及她要杀了约翰。但每个人，包括约翰在内，都把这当成毫无意义的威胁一笑了之。在一次争吵中，她对约翰说：“你永远休想赶我离开这栋房子。我要先把你做掉。”但随着时间推移，凯茜能感觉到两人的关系开始滑向深渊。
And that made her furious. In 1998, she started secretly filming items in John's house. She alleges he stole from the mine where he worked at the time. Ridiculous things, like a can of bug spray, an old first aid kit that had expired, things like that. Cathy said she did this as John used to hit her. And she made the video to hold it over John, that if he ever touched her again, she would send the videos to his boss.
这让她勃然大怒。1998年，她开始秘密拍摄约翰家里的物品。她指控他偷窃了当时工作的矿场的物品。一些荒谬的东西，比如一罐杀虫剂、一个过期的旧急救包，诸如此类。凯茜说她这样做是因为约翰过去经常打她。她制作这段视频是为了以此拿捏约翰，如果他敢再打她，她就把视频发给他的老板。
But the truth was, John had told Cathy he wanted her out of his house. And it was now time for Cathy to get her revenge. Most of the stuff on the video hadn't been stolen from the mine at all. And what had been taken from the mine was old discarded junk that would have been thrown out anyway, including the old first aid kit. Cathy sent the video to John's bosses at the mine, and after they viewed it, she invited them into John's house and pointed out all of the items to them in person.
但事实是，约翰曾告诉凯茜他希望她搬出自己的房子。现在轮到凯茜去复仇了。视频中的大部分东西根本不是从矿场偷的。而那些从矿场拿走的东西都是些本来就会被扔掉的陈旧废弃垃圾，包括那个旧急救包。凯茜把视频发给了约翰在矿场的老板，在他们观看后，她邀请他们来到约翰家，并当面指出了所有的物品。
The first aid kit was the downfall. Even though it was out of date and they could prove it was out of date, and it was going to be thrown out anyway, the mine sacked John. 17 years of service gone, just like that. He had worked hard over the years to put himself in a position that earned him $100,000 a year, and now it was all gone. John immediately kicked Cathy out of his house. But unbelievably, it didn't last.
那个急救包成了压垮他的最后一根稻草。尽管它已经过期，并且他们能证明它已过期，而且无论如何都会被扔掉，矿场还是解雇了约翰。17年的服务就这样付诸东流。这些年来，他通过努力工作让自己达到了年薪10万美元的地位，而现在这一切都没了。约翰立刻把凯茜赶出了他的家。但难以置信的是，这种情况并没有持续多久。
It wasn't long before John became lonely. He started blaming himself for what had happened. His mates couldn't believe what they were hearing, but a few months later, John and Cathy were back together. But this time, she didn't move back into John's house. Still, his decision to get back with Cathy actually cost John some friendships, and it caused drama with his son Jonathan, who already hated Cathy before she got John sacked,
没过多久，约翰就开始感到孤独。他开始为发生的事情自责。他的朋友们简直不敢相信他们所听到的，但在几个月后，约翰和凯茜又复合了。但这一次，她没有搬回约翰的家。不过，他决定和凯茜复合确实让他失去了一些友谊，并与他的儿子乔纳森产生了矛盾，乔纳森在约翰被开除前就已经讨厌凯茜了，
and now he hated her even more. When they were discussing getting back together, Cathy told John, if you take me back, this time it's to the death. It wasn't long before the argument started again, and they increased in violence. Most of the fights this time were over John losing his job at the mine, but John did go on to get another job. Cathy was also starting to cause trouble with John s youngest daughter.
现在他更加痛恨她了。在他们讨论复合时，凯茜对约翰说：“如果你接受我复合，这一次就是至死方休。”没过多久，争吵再次爆发，并且暴力程度升级了。这一次大多数争吵都是因为约翰失去了矿上的工作，但约翰后来确实又找到了一份工作。凯茜也开始找约翰小女儿的麻烦。
She lived with her mother Colleen, but visited John and Cathy regularly. John s son and eldest daughter had moved out of home and had their own families. Cathy s two eldest daughters, Melissa and Natasha, had also moved out of home. But her two youngest kids still lived with her. Cathy started telling John s youngest daughter things like John wasn't really her dad, and other nasty, spiteful things like that. When John confronted her about it, Cathy was doing the dishes. So she lunged at him with a knife.
她和母亲科琳住在一起，但定期探望约翰和凯茜。约翰的儿子和大女儿已经搬出家门并有了自己的家庭。凯茜的两个大女儿梅丽莎和娜塔莎也已经搬出家门。但她最小的两个孩子仍然和她住在一起。凯茜开始对约翰的小女儿说一些诸如“约翰其实不是你亲爸”之类的话，还有其他令人讨厌、恶毒的言论。当约翰为此与她对质时，凯茜正在洗碗。于是她拿着一把刀猛地朝他扑过去。
Cathy stabbed him in the upper left chest. John didn't seek treatment, he just put a bandaid on it, and never reported it to police. The stab wound left a permanent scar. Towards the end of 1999, Cathy enlisted the help of her nephew, and instructed him to steal John s car, which was worth about $20,000, but it was uninsured. She told her nephew to burn it.
凯茜刺中了约翰的左上胸部。约翰没有去求医，只是贴了个创可贴，也从未向警方报案。这个刺伤留下了永久的疤处。1999年底，凯茜拉拢她的外甥，指使他去偷约翰的车，那辆车价值约2万美元，但没有买保险。她叫外甥把它烧了。
She offered to pay him $500 to do it. Not satisfied with hurting him financially, Cathy later asked her nephew to throw battery acid on his face. Her nephew refused both requests. Cathy later said to her older brother, I'm going to kill Pricey, and I'm going to get away with it. I'll get away with it because I'll make out I'm mad. Meanwhile, John Price desperately wanted to end the relationship with Cathy for a second time.
她提出付给他500美元来做这件事。不满足于在经济上伤害他，凯茜后来还让外甥把蓄电池酸液泼到他脸上。她的外甥拒绝了这两个要求。凯茜后来对她的大哥说：“我要杀了普赖西，而且我能逃脱惩罚。我能逃脱是因为我会伪装成疯了。”与此同时，约翰·普赖斯迫切地想要第二次结束与凯茜的关系。
But he couldn't work out how. There was just no way that he could see for a peaceful separation. He was also worried that Cathy might start to target his children if he ended it. During the afternoon of February 27, the year 2000, another physical fight occurred. During the fight, John thought Cathy went for a knife. Having already been stabbed by her before, he took off and sought refuge at her neighbor's house.
但他不知道该怎么做。在他看来，根本没有和平分手的可能。如果结束这段关系，他还担心凯茜可能会把目标对准他的孩子们。2000年2月27日下午，又一场肢体冲突发生了。在争斗过程中，约翰认为凯茜去拿刀了。由于之前已经被她刺伤过，他立刻逃跑，并在邻居家找到了避难所。
John called the police. He had scratches all over him from the fight. But Cathy had bruises as well. John told the police he wanted Cathy out of his house. She had her own place in town where she could go and stay. They told him there was nothing they could do and he would need a court order. By now, the relationship had been going for six years, on and off. There had been great highs and dark lows.
约翰报了警。他身上布满了打斗留下的抓痕。但凯茜身上也有淤青。约翰告诉警察他想把凯茜赶出他的家。她在镇上有自己的住所，可以去那里住。他们告诉他他们无能为力，他需要法院的禁止令。此时，这段关系已经分分合合持续了六年。期间有过极乐，也有过黑暗的低谷。
And that night, as had happened many times before, they made up after the argument and John went to bed. At 2.30am the next morning, Monday the 28th of February, John woke up startled. He could make out the silhouette of Cathy standing over him at the bed. Her arms were behind her back. He jumped out of bed frightened Cathy had a knife. But she didn't.
那天晚上，就像过去很多次那样，他们在争吵后和好了，约翰上床睡觉了。第二天凌晨2点30分，即2月28日星期一，约翰惊醒了。他能辨认出凯茜站在床边俯视他的剪影。她的双手背在身后。他吓得跳下床，担心凯茜拿着刀。但她没有。
John went to work that day. He recounted the last day's events to his workmates. They had never seen him so distressed. He said he thought he was a dead man when he woke up to see Cathy standing over him with her hands behind her back that morning. His boss offered John to go and stay with him for a while. But he refused. That night John returned home and actually had a civil discussion with Cathy.
约翰那天去上班了。他向同事们讲述了前一天的经历。他们从未见他说得如此心力交瘁。他说，当那天早上醒来看到凯茜双手背在身后站在他上方时，他觉得自己死定了。他的老板提出让约翰去他那里住一段时间。但他拒绝了。那天晚上，约翰回到家，实际上与凯茜进行了一次文明的讨论。
They agreed they couldn't go on the way they were. But Cathy again refused to leave his house. That night the police arrived with the restraining order which they served on John. They took the order out as a result of the fight the night before. The 29th of February the year 2000 began like most other days. Cathy woke up early and got John organised for work. She cooked him breakfast and made his lunch. John went to work and got permission of his boss to go to the local courthouse
他们同意不能再这样继续下去了。但凯茜再次拒绝离开他的家。那天晚上，警察带着他们送达给约翰的禁止令赶到了。这是因为前一天晚上的争斗，他们才下达了这项禁令。2000年2月29日这一天像大多数日子一样开始了。凯茜早早醒来，帮约翰准备上班。她给他做早餐，准备午饭。约翰去上班，并获得了老板的批准，前往当地法院
to apply for his own restraining order against Cathy. Meanwhile Cathy went and saw her solicitor and dropped in on a few old friends showing them the bruises she had after the fight with John. Two nights ago she told one of her friends that bastard is not going to get away with this. I'm going to bloody get him. She made an appointment with her doctor and had the injuries recorded. John saw the chamber magistrate at Musselbrook courthouse around lunchtime.
申请针对凯茜的禁止令。与此同时，凯茜去见她的律师，并顺便拜访了几位老朋友，向她们展示她与约翰打架后身上的淤青。两天前，她对其中一位朋友说：“那个混蛋休想逃脱。我非要血洗他不可。”她预约了医生，并将伤情记录在案。约翰在午餐时间左右来到了马塞尔布鲁克法院见治安法官。
He explained the relationship issues he and Cathy had including all the violent incidents. He said he wanted to stop Cathy from being able to enter his house. After telling his story the chamber magistrate issued a restraining order against Cathy. That night John made his way to the top pub. Cathy took her children out for dinner. After dinner she asked Natasha if her two youngest children could stay the night at her house. Natasha agreed. Natasha being Cathy's second oldest child if you forgot.
他解释了他和凯茜之间的感情问题，包括所有的暴力事件。他说他想阻止凯茜进入他的房子。听完他的讲述后，治安法官向凯茜发出了禁止令。那天晚上，约翰去了顶楼酒吧。凯茜带着孩子们出去吃晚饭。晚饭后，她问娜塔莎她最小的两个孩子是否可以在她家过夜。娜塔莎同意了。如果你忘了的话，娜塔莎是凯茜的第二个大孩子。
John made his way home about 9.30pm. Cathy arrived at his place about 11pm. She had a key to John's house and let herself in. But there was no fighting, no arguing. John didn't tell Cathy to leave. Instead they had sex. The restraining orders were just words and a piece of paper at that point. The next morning John didn't chart for work.
约翰大约在晚上9点30分回家。凯茜大约在晚上11点到达他的住处。她有约翰家的钥匙，自己开门进去了。但没有打斗，没有争吵。约翰没有叫凯茜离开。相反，他们发生了性关系。当时，禁止令不过是纸上谈兵和几张废纸而已。第二天早上，约翰没有去上班。
Something he never did. He always turned up for work. He was reliable. He hadn't called in or let anyone know he was running late. People from work tried ringing him numerous times but they couldn't get a hold of him. They even called the police to see if there had been any car accidents that morning. But they hadn't. As he was leaving for work one of John's neighbours spotted John's car still parked out the front of his house.
这与他平时的作风大相径庭。他总是按时上班。他是个靠谱的人。他既没有打电话请假，也没有让任何人知道他迟到了。同事们多次打电话给他，但都联系不上他。他们甚至打电话给警察，看看那天早上是否发生了车祸。但并没有。正当约翰的一个邻居出门上班时，他发现约翰的车仍然停在他家门前。
That was unusual. John always left for work before him. His car was never there at that time. John's work colleagues decided they better call the police. Police arrived at John's house at about 10 past eight that morning. Two of the first officers on the scene were Officer Matthews. I was actually working at Musclebrook that day and received a phone call at the station from a workmate of Mr Price's. And Officer Furlonga.
这很不寻常。约翰总是比他先出门上班。这个时间他的车从不在这里。约翰的同事们决定最好还是报警。警察当天早上8点10分左右抵达了约翰的住宅。现场最早到达的警员之一是马修斯警官。我那天其实在马塞尔布鲁克工作，并接到了一位普赖斯先生同事从警局打来的电话。还有富隆加警官。
I got the call from his boss saying that he hadn't come in and somebody had been out there and that you'd been still in the driveway and they couldn't raise anybody. You know, not thinking the worst, we were just thinking, oh yeah, he's probably died one on or something. It hasn't woken up. I knew Mr Price before. I knew that he was a hard worker and a reliable man, so it was a bit unusual for him not to turn up to work and not to make a phone call. I went up, knocked on the door, didn't get an answer, saw some blood on the door handle, looked for a little gap into the lounge room which was dark, reasonably dark, and saw what looked like a bunched up curtain hanging down. I couldn't raise anybody so I decided to go and break into the place seeing as we had this complaint.
我接到他老板的电话，说他没去上班，有人去过他家，发现他的车还停在车道上，而且怎么也联系不上他。你知道的，我们当时没有往最坏处想，只觉得，哦，也许他在哪里耽搁了，或者还没醒。我以前认识普莱斯先生。我知道他是一个工作努力、靠谱的人，所以他没去上班也没打个电话，这有点反常。我走过去敲了门，没人应，看到门把手上有一些血迹，透过客厅的一个小缝隙往里看里面很黑，可以说是相当黑，看到有什么东西像一团垂下来的窗帘。我叫不到任何人，既然我们接到了这个投诉，我决定破门而入。
Walked around the side, there was some meat lying on the ground. Anyway, went round the back, broke in through the door. As we went in I saw straight ahead what I thought was a curtain. There was something hanging, blocking my entry into the hallway of the house. I thought it looked like some type of blanket or some sort of covering that had been placed up on the archway. So I remember I used my left hand to push it aside and immediately I could feel coldness coming on my left arm. So I looked down and my left arm was just covered in blood. Initially I thought I'd injure myself breaking through the back door.
我绕到侧面，地上有一些肉。不管怎样，我绕到后面，从门破门而入。当我们进去时，我一眼就看到了我以为是窗帘的东西。有什么东西挂在那里，挡住了我进入房屋走廊的去路。我觉得它看起来像某种毯子或某种挂在拱门上的遮盖物。所以我记得我用左手把它推开，立刻我就能感到一股寒意袭上我的左臂。所以我低头一看，我的左臂全都是血。起初我以为是自己砸后门时弄伤了。
I couldn't understand why my arm was bleeding. I realised then it was a human pelt, it was a skin, minus the head. The full skin just hanging from the top door frame. I looked past it, sort of torso on the ground without a head, without any genitalia, and my first reaction then was to turn around to Scotty and say, don't look Scotty. Of course that's the worst thing you can say. I could look through from there into the lounge room and I saw what appeared to be a human being or what was left.
我不明白为什么我的手臂在流血。我当时意识到那是一张人类的毛皮，是一张皮，没有头。整张皮就挂在顶部的门框上。我越过它看去，地上似乎有个没有头、没有生殖器的躯干，我当时的第一个反应就是转身对斯科蒂说，别看，斯科蒂。当然，那是你能说的最糟糕的话。我可以从那里看到客厅里有什么东西，或者说剩下的人形。
And so it was at that point that I realised what had happened. For something that I'd never seen before, I'd never experienced. I had an immediate idea of what had gone on. It was at that point I drew my service pistol. There was blood everywhere, a lot of blood out from the door into the kitchen area. There's a pot on the stove. I think I might have even said to Scotty, I'll give you one guess where the head is. On the table there was a couple of plates that had meals prepared, vegetables and meat cooked sitting there.
就在那时，我意识到发生了什么。对于我从未见过、从未经历过的事情，我立刻就有了发生了什么的预感。就在那时，我拔出了配枪。到处都是血，从门口到厨房区域有很多血。炉子上有一个锅。我想我甚至可能对斯科蒂说过，我让你猜猜头在哪里。桌上有几盘已经准备好的饭菜，煮熟的蔬菜和肉放在那里。
Sergeant Furlonga was talking to me saying it's going to be alright, we've got to keep going, we've got to finish this, we've got to do whatever it takes. He was talking to me and I was trying to hear if I could hear anybody else, because sometimes a little bit under stress, you get that auditory exclusion and you're not hearing things. You're just focused on the threat. It was quite a frightening experience, but once you've stepped into that situation, there's just no backing out. So we went to search the place and we went up the hallway. We heard what appeared to be someone snoring coming from one of the bedrooms.
弗洛隆加警长跟我说话，说会没事的，我们得继续前进，我们得完成这件事，我们得不惜一切代价。他在跟我说话，而我正试图听听能否听到其他人的声音，因为有时在压力下，你会产生那种听觉排除效应，听不到声音。你只专注于威胁。这是一次相当可怕的经历，但一旦你踏入了那种境地，就没有退路了。所以我们去搜查那个地方，走进了走廊。我们听到其中一个卧室里似乎有人打鼾的声音。
So we knew there was someone alive in the house. Looked in there and there she was lying on the bed, tried to wake her. She was obviously drugged on something and couldn't wake her properly, she was very groggy. She wasn't responding, so we carried her outside and put her onto the back lawn. I wasn't sure if she had tried to kill herself with sleeping pills or whatever, but she certainly wasn't injured in any way. They handcuffed Kathy and tried to question her, but they couldn't get any sense out of her. There were some empty blister packs located and they worked out Kathy had tried to kill herself by overdosing on tablets. And the ambulance was called until she was taken to hospital, where she was kept in the psychiatric ward.
所以我们知道屋里还有一个活人。往里一看，她就躺在床上，试图叫醒她。她显然是嗑了什么药，怎么也叫不醒，人非常迷糊。她没有反应，于是我们把她抬到外面，放在后草坪上。我不知道她是想用安眠药自杀还是怎么的，但她确实没有受到任何伤害。他们给凯茜戴上手铐并试图讯问她，但从她嘴里问不出什么名堂。现场发现了一些空的药泡板，他们推断凯茜是通过吞服过量药片来试图自杀。随后叫了救护车，她被送往医院，并被关在精神病房里。
Obviously, police had great fears for Kathy's youngest children. After a frantic period of searching, they managed to locate them safe and well at Natasha's house. Crime scene officer Peter Masio was then called to examine the scene. I got a phone call from VKG, which is police radio, telling us there had been a murder. I said to the operator, well how do you know it's a murder? And they said, well, he's been decapitated. We came in through the laundry at the back of the premises and there was an aroma and it was, well, it's quite a macabre thing. It was a sweet odor, a nice odor, as if mum was cooking a stew. Walk inside and one of the first things you see is Mr Price's skin or pelt hanging from the door from a meat hook.
显然，警方对凯茜最小的孩子们感到非常担心。经过一阵疯狂的搜寻，他们设法在娜塔莎的家里找到了他们，他们安然无恙。犯罪现场警官彼得·马西奥随后被召来检查现场。我接到VKG（即警方无线电）的电话，告诉我们发生了一起谋杀案。我对接线员说，你怎么知道这是一起谋杀？他们说，呃，他被斩首了。我们从房舍后方的洗衣房进去，有一股气味，那是，嗯，这是一件相当毛骨悚然的事情。那是一种甜美的气味，一种好闻的气味，就像妈妈在炖汤一样。走进去，你看到的景象之一就是普莱斯先生的皮挂在肉钩的门上。
I searched through the pelt for Mr Price's genitals. Further into the kitchen, you could see bloodstaining on certain items and into the lounge room, there was a body. Further down the hallway, there was bloodstaining going into the bedrooms. You could see where I think Mr Price had gone for a light switch. There was bloodstaining on the light switch and also blood that he has coughed or something on the wall. You could see the expiration mark on it. But as you go out towards the lounge room, these blood stains are getting heavier and heavier. There's big swipes where his blood soaked himself and sliding against the wall.
我在皮张中搜寻普莱斯先生的生殖器。再往厨房走，你可以看到某些物品上有血迹，客厅里有一具尸体。再往下走是通往卧室的血迹。你能看到普莱斯先生去按电灯开关的地方。电灯开关上有血迹，墙上还有他咳嗽之类的血迹。你能看到上面喷溅的痕迹。但当你走向客厅时，这些血迹越来越重。有大片血迹，是他的血浸透了自己，然后身体靠着墙壁滑过。
They're also getting lower. It comes to a combination at the foyer where he's just succumbed to his injuries. He's actually opened the front door and there's blood splatter on the screen, so he's nearly made it out. Not that it would have helped him. He would have died, certainly. You just see the enormity of where it starts in the bedroom and progressively gets worse and worse. Do you get to that point where he's died? The blood pool was the width of the hallway, which was 1.2 metres wide. When we examined the body, you could see the body has been there in its entirety.
它们也越来越低。在门厅汇集到一起，他在那里终于支撑不住伤势倒下了。他其实已经打开了前门，防盗门上有血迹溅落，所以他差一点就逃出去了。倒不是说这能救他的命。他肯定还是会死的。你只需看看它在卧室开始并逐渐恶化的巨大规模。你到了他死亡的那个地方吗？血泊有走廊那么宽，也就是1.2米宽。当我们检查尸体时，你可以看到尸体是完整地呆在那里的。
There's a big stain on the floor where the head would have been. It's been skinned first. You can see it. She placed the skin on the carpet to sit it there and it's quite substantial staining. There's also an outline of the head, so she's taken the head off there. You can see that she's walked in carrying it into the kitchen. There's this drip, drip, drip of blood all the way leading to the cooktop. But until we actually lifted the lid off, it wasn't confirmed. To me, it was a statement. She had cut the gluteus maximus off his backside.
地上有一个大血迹，原本应该是头部的位置。她是先剥皮的。你能看出来。她把皮放在地毯上，那里的血迹相当明显。还有一个头部的轮廓，所以她把头从那里拿走了。你可以看到她提着它走进了厨房。有一滴一滴的血一直通向灶台。但直到我们真正掀开锅盖，才得到证实。对我来说，这是一个宣泄。她割下了他屁股上的臀大肌。
It's a big muscle and she's cut that into five different steaks and she's cooked them, baked them in the oven. Two of them were on one plate, two on another plate and the fifth was out for the dog, I believe. It wasn't touched. But the meals, they were like a trophy and they had the names of each person who was supposed to get them. There were two prepared meals on the table, complete with meat and vegetables. A piece of paper was placed next to each meal. A name was scribbled on each piece of paper. One was for John's son, the other for his youngest daughter.
那是一块大肌肉，她把它切成了五块不同的牛排，然后在烤箱里烤了。其中两块在一个盘子里，两块在另一个盘子里，第五块我猜是留给狗的。它没有被动过。但那些饭菜，它们就像一个奖杯，上面写着每个应该得到它们的人的名字。桌上有两份准备好的饭菜，配有肉和蔬菜。每顿饭旁边都放着一张纸。每张纸上都潦草地写着一个名字。一份是给约翰的儿子的，另一份是给他的小女儿的。
Officer Masio then examined the rest of the scene and collected all of the evidence. It didn't take long for news of the murder to spread. There were a few, I told you so's, and I knew she was capable of that amongst the Aberdeen community. During the course of their investigation, police found that after Cathy had murdered John, she cleaned herself up and drove into town and withdrew $1,000 from his bank account. To this day, it's unknown what she did with that money. Cathy was charged with the murder of John Price in a special bedside sitting in the psychiatric ward of the hospital she was being held in on the 7th of March, 2000.
马西奥警官随后检查了现场的其余部分并收集了所有证据。谋杀案的消息很快就传开了。阿伯丁社区里有少数人说“我早就告诉过你”以及“我知道她有这种能力”。在调查过程中，警方发现凯茜谋杀约翰后，清理了自己，然后开车进城，从他的银行账户里取出了1000美元。直到今天，她用这笔钱做了什么仍然是个谜。2000年3月7日，凯茜在她被关押的医院精神病房里通过特别床边开庭，被指控谋杀约翰·普莱斯。
When interviewed by police, she denied having any knowledge about John's death, although she did admit she was responsible for his death. She claimed she had amnesia and couldn't remember how it happened. It became clear to police after speaking with Cathy that she was intending to mount a defence of battered wife syndrome, that she had committed the crime due to years of being the victim of severe domestic violence. Police got to work investigating that angle, and as you've already heard, they quickly realised that yes,
当警方讯问时，她否认对约翰的死有任何了解，尽管她确实承认自己对他的死负有责任。她声称自己患有失忆症，记不清是怎么发生的了。在与凯茜交谈后，警方逐渐明白，她打算提出遭受虐待妻子综合症的辩护，即她是因为多年来一直是严重家庭暴力的受害者而犯罪的。警方开始着手调查这个角度，正如你已经听到的那样，他们很快意识到，是的，
Cathy had been in some extremely violent relationships, but she was the cause of that violence. She wasn't the victim of it. Cathy was examined by numerous psychiatrists. They determined yes, Cathy suffered from personality disorder. But a personality disorder is not actually considered a psych illness. They found Cathy's violence and rages were just part of her nature, part of her makeup. She got a sick sense of enjoyment out of what she did.
凯茜曾有过一些极其暴力的恋爱关系，但她才是暴力的制造者。她不是受害者。许多精神病学家对凯茜进行了检查。他们确定，是的，凯茜患有人格障碍。但人格障碍实际上不被认为是一种精神疾病。他们发现凯茜的暴力和暴怒只是她本性的一部分，是她性格的一部分。她从自己的所作所为中获得了变态的快感。
Cathy's claims that she couldn't remember anything about the crime were dismissed. She was basically putting on a show. It was found that her actions were premeditated and the timing was planned. She knew exactly what she was doing. She wasn't suffering from a psychiatric illness at all. She was just pure evil. Cathy initially pled not guilty and her trial started on the 15th of October 2001. The judge assigned to the case was the Honourable Barry O'Keefe.
凯茜关于她不记得任何犯罪细节的说法被驳回了。她基本上是在演戏。研究发现，她的行为是预谋的，时间也是计划好的。她完全知道自己在做什么。她根本没有患精神疾病。她简直纯粹是恶魔。凯茜最初对指控不认罪，她的审判于2001年10月15日开始。指派给该案的法官是巴里·奥基夫大法官。
At no time as either a barrister or as a judge, did I ever strike anything of the horrific nature of Catherine Mary Knight's case. She pleaded not guilty and the trial began in the conventional way. She sat in the dock, she was quite small, unimpressive. In a crowd you'd certainly never notice her. Before the trial got going, Cathy surprised everyone and changed the plea to guilty. I was somewhat nervous about this because I was concerned that if I took a guilty plea, sentenced her, she would then appeal to the Court of Criminal Appeal
无论作为大律师还是法官，我从未遇到过任何像凯瑟琳·玛丽·奈特案这样骇人听闻的事情。她不认罪，审判以常规方式开始。她坐在被告席上，身材矮小，毫不起眼。在人群中你绝对不会注意到她。在审判开始前，凯茜让所有人大吃一惊，将罪名改为了认罪。我对此有点紧张，因为我担心如果我接受认罪并判处她刑罚，她随后会向刑事上诉法院提起上诉
and say she was insane at the time that she made the plea of guilty. I decided that I should get a court expert to examine her and the psychiatrist came to exactly the same conclusion as the other psychiatrist that had seen it. Namely that she was not insane, she was quite sane, but she was a bad woman. Throughout the whole of the evidence, it didn't matter what the witness said, she didn't look at the witness. It didn't matter what the photograph or video was, she didn't look at that.
并辩称她在认罪时精神失常。我决定应该让法院专家对她进行检查，精神病学家的结论与其他见过她的精神病学家的结论完全一致。即她没有精神失常，她完全神志清醒，但她是个坏女人。在所有的证据审理过程中，无论证人说什麽，她都不看证人。无论照片或视频是什麽，她都不看。
She sat looking straight ahead, absolutely impassive. There was never a sign on her face of any reaction to any of the evidence. At one point during the sentencing hearing, when some of the graphic details were being presented to the court, Cathy broke down. She started rocking violently back and forth and started screaming. She came down to the floor and started threshing about, but she wasn't fooling anybody.
她直视前方坐着，绝对无动于衷。对于任何证据，她的脸上从未出现过任何反应的迹象。在量刑听证会的一次审理中，当一些令人毛骨悚然的细节被呈现在法庭上时，凯茜崩溃了。她开始剧烈地前后摇晃并尖叫起来。她倒在地上开始痛苦地挣扎，但她并没有愚弄任何人。
When she wanted an adjournment, she manipulated her behaviour so that she got it. Thereafter, she resumed the same man that she had before, but I didn't think that she'd switched off. In sentencing, the judge found that Cathy's suicide attempt wasn't a genuine attempt. He didn't believe that she couldn't remember anything about the crime. He determined she knew exactly what she was doing. She acted with planning and premeditation. She had openly said many times she was going to kill John.
当她想要休庭时，她操纵自己的行为以达到目的。此后，她恢复了先前的神态，但我并不认为她已经收敛了。在量刑时，法官发现凯茜的自杀未遂并不是一次真诚的尝试。他不相信她对犯罪过程毫无记忆。他认定她完全知道自己在做什么。她是带着计划和预谋行事的。她曾公开多次说过她要杀了约翰。
She had even said she would get away with it because people would think she was mad. The judge found her to be vengeful, violent, and believed she was an extreme danger to society. He dismissed her claims of battered wife syndrome, finding that the evidence clearly showed she was the violent one in her relationships. As a result, Cathy Knight became the first woman in Australia to be sentenced to imprisonment for the term of her natural life. No possibility of parole.
她甚至说过她会逃脱惩罚，因为人们会以为她疯了。法官认为她心狠手辣、暴力成性，并认为她对社会极其危险。他驳回了她关于遭受虐待妻子综合症的说法，认为证据清楚地表明她是关系中的暴力制造者。因此，凯茜·奈特成为澳大利亚第一位被判处终身监禁的女性。不得假释。
To sentence any person to life imprisonment is a big thing. To sentence a woman to life imprisonment for me was an even bigger thing. This was as bad a case as you got, so she had to go to jail for the term of her life. She'd shown no remorse. She hadn't acknowledged that she had any problem at all. Such a person, if released, is not unlikely to do the same again. There's a real prospect of it.
判处任何人终身监禁都是一件大事。对我来说，判处一名女性终身监禁是一件更大的一件事。这是一起极其恶劣的案件，所以她必须在监狱里度过她的余生。她没有表现出丝毫悔意。她没有承认自己有任何问题。这样的人如果被释放，并非不可能再次作案。确实存在这种可能性。
The detective in charge of the case was Detective Bob Wells. When I was interviewing Catherine, you can catch someone's eye and you say to yourself, I'm being bullshitted here. It's a combination of catching their eye, catching the expression on their face, that you know that this person is feeding you only what she wants to feed you. And that's why I still believe that Catherine would now be able to provide information as to what took place and why it took place.
负责该案的侦探是鲍勃·韦尔斯侦探。当我采访凯瑟琳时，你可以抓住一个人的眼神，然后对自己说，我在这里被忽悠了。这是抓住他们的眼神、抓住他们脸上的表情的结合，让你知道这个人只在向你提供她想提供的信息。这就是为什么我仍然相信凯瑟琳现在能够提供关于发生了什么以及为什么发生的信息。
After a while of doing jail time, Cathy said that she'd finally found peace and she was enjoying her time. But she obviously didn't like the idea of spending the rest of her life there because she appealed to the New South Wales Court of Criminal Appeal. She claimed her sentence was too harsh. Thankfully, the court rejected her appeal and she will spend the rest of her life behind bars. To this day, she has never given a reason for what she did or why she did it.
在服刑一段时间后，凯茜说她终于找到了平静，并且很享受她的时光。但她显然不喜欢在余生都呆在那里的想法，因为她向新南威尔士州刑事上诉法院提出了上诉。她声称她的刑罚太重了。谢天谢地，法院驳回了她的上诉，她将在狱中度过余生。直到今天，她从未对她所做的事情或原因给出一个解释。
And she has never shown any remorse. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且她从未表现出任何悔意。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。